I'm gonna start with like a little
introduction of myself I study Earth's
ice sheets and I got interested in this
as a math student as an undergraduate
math student I had the opportunity to
work as an intern on a project about
tipping icebergs and that was really fun
it piqued my interest I came back to New
York and worked at the lamont-doherty
Earth Observatory where I modeled the
ocean floor around Greenland from
gravity data collected by an airplane I
had the opportunity to do field work in
both Greenland and Antarctica and since
becoming a graduate student I worked on
some time series problems some virtual
reality projects and my research
interests have evolved to study not the
bottom of the ice anymore but but the
surface I don't do this by myself this
is a picture of my adviser Robin Bell
and I work with her and many other
scientists and engineers on projects
such as this one this is the ice pod
there are very many scientists and
engineers who are focused on new
techniques for measuring the ice sheets
understanding how they're changing and
figuring out what what causes that
change what are the physical processes
involved in how the ice sheets are are
flowing evolving and losing mass we care
about these regions in the north and the
south
Greenland of the the northern hemisphere
ice sheet Antarctica is the southern
hemisphere ice sheet and together they
contain about 90 percent of the world's
freshwater I added the United States
here for scale so that you can get a
sense of how much ice is in each in each
hemisphere an ice sheet is a large area
of ice that's in contact with the rock
underneath and it flows under the force
of gravity by its own weight sort of out
from the center out to the oceans we
care about these areas because together
if all of the ice melted it would raise
sea level by about 65 meters and that
would have implications for the
coastline
where
most of us live and as a background to
continue the background anyway I'm gonna
talk about three ways that we know by
measuring from space how the ice sheets
are changing so I'm going to show two
videos the first one all right here we
go
so you're zooming in on a region in West
Antarctica called Pine Island glacier
and the first thing you're gonna see is
velocity data from the mid 90s so you
can tell that it's speeding up as time
goes on and so more ice is flowing from
the middle of the continent out towards
the ocean the second measurement that
you can make from space is height change
so as you go on in time you can see it's
a read of the is a is thinning and as
you go on you can see that the ice
sheets are thinning and they're thinning
in the places but they're that they're
flowing faster so those are two two
measurements that we can make to
document the change there's another one
also from satellites this is this is a
satellite that actually measures of
gravity and from that we can infer mass
loss and red shows a mass loss of blue
shows a mass gain by the way the glacier
that you were looking at before Pine
Island is right here in this area where
we know that a lot of mass is being as
being lost so those are three direct
measurements that that we can make that
that shows change on pretty fast
timescales so I mentioned before that
the ice sheets are grounded on bedrock
but around the edges where they're
flowing out towards the ocean the ice
actually comes up off the rock and is
floating on the water and these are the
areas that I study they're called ice
shelves I've marked three of them here
the larson and the Nansen I'm going to
talk about later and then I marked the
Ross here because this is where I got to
go a couple a couple of years ago and
these two diagrams are showing the cross
section of I like a diagram above what
what the ice shelves look like and it's
included the surface melting which is
which is what I study so in the top
panel you're seeing a pattern where ice
is being melt ice is be melted the water
is collecting into ponds and then there
are our crevasses in the floating
part of the ice shelf are of the ice the
ice shelf and the ponds can can
propagate these crevasses or fractures
all the way through to the ice thickness
and break pieces off the bottom panel
shows a different type of system a
different pattern where you mount the
ice maybe you've got some ponds but
actually the water can get transported
long distances by rivers and these can
end up in water falls off the edge of
the a of the ice shelf there are two
examples real-world examples of this the
first was probably you might remember
it's kind of a dramatic a dramatic event
the Larsen B Ice Shelf in West
Antarctica had been stable for thousands
of years and if you look at this top
image you can kind of see there are very
many ponds that are forming on the
surface there are thousands of these
lakes they're arrayed in a very special
pattern and in 35 days a piece of ice
around the size of Rhode Island
disintegrated and that's because of the
way this do this process and this
diagram that the the ponds are able to
to crack and fracture the ice and if you
have them arrayed in a certain way you
can get a disintegration event like this
one recently we've seen evidence for the
other pattern shown in the schematic so
this is the Nansen ice shelf and in this
satellite image you can kind of see that
there are ponds here the same way that
there were in the Larsen B but there's
also a river that runs down transports
water across this shelf and empties it
out into the ocean this is a picture of
what that of what that waterfall looks
like it's very impressive and because
everybody likes movies I'm gonna show
you a movie of the waterfall so the the
ice shelf is in the background I'll play
it one more time you can see the the
waterfall falling off the shelf and then
in front of that is the ocean it's just
it's covered in an iceberg so so that's
what these things kind of look like and
these two observations have led to this
question Ken rivers by removing water
protect ice
from breaking apart so I'm really
interested in how the spatial pattern of
water on the top of ice shelves can
affect its behavior the way that I think
about this is in terms of a total budget
so you could imagine that the amount of
water that you melt should be equal to
the amount that you store versus the
amount that you remove and today I'm
going to talk about the amount that is
stored and I try to estimate this volume
from satellite images and I do this an
ice shelf in Greenland called
computermen ice shelf so just to orient
you the ice is flowing from the bottom
here towards the top all of this is the
ocean
there are icebergs and it's it's flanked
on either side by by rock ice is flowing
in from the side you can see some ponds
maybe this image is a little bit too
small but you can see some ponds here
there are also ponds all the way out
towards towards the edge of the shelf
there are two rivers one that runs down
the center line actually there more than
two one main one that runs down the
center line there's a meandering one off
to the side there's another one here and
this person actually did kayak down this
main river that we know empties into a
waterfall so fun or dangerous assignment
I'm not really sure but it happened so
to show you what the data actually look
like I just made a small movie of the
area that was shown in the red box
before of how the water evolves over the
course of about a month in 2016 so I'll
play it a couple of times but you should
probably be able to convince yourselves
that the pattern changes in time and
pretty quickly too so you can see lakes
that form and then by the end there are
fewer some of them may be drained some
of them persist I'll play it one more
time so in the beginning there's there's
water everywhere lots of lots of lakes
these tend these disappear really
rapidly the river runs down the middle
and so I think looking at this it's
it's easy to ask yourself well it are
these pawns connected the river is the
river draining the water how is the
water how is the water moving and
there's clear evidence that it that it
is changing from day to day so looking
at these images as well as reading very
many studies by other people I'm not the
only person interested in this question
this is a big area of research I've I've
kind of broken it up into patterns that
I think we see and that might be
important that might actually like sort
of define and members of a spectrum of
behavior so in Antarctica this is my
little diagram of what the the Larsen B
example would be you have a lot of lakes
there they're spaced in some regular way
and and this is the this is the type
that could could break a brick and ice
shelf in Greenland like what I just
showed you there are some bigger lakes
clustered upstream there smaller ones
that are downstream there are fewer
lakes here there are other places in
Antarctica where the lakes are much
bigger but they're concentrated in an
area where you would expect a lot of
melting and then in terms of the river
is both Greenland and Antarctica have
these these rivers that get all the way
to the edge and and end in a waterfall
and they they have really similar shapes
they're they're kind of long and linear
we think that they might be there
because of the way that the ice moves
and also the way that the ice interacts
with the ocean there are also much
wiggly rivers and I'm not really sure I
don't think that they are controlled by
the same process that that makes the
long skinny ones so a little bit about
the data that I use you saw some
satellite data yesterday I mostly look
at
Landsat images so Landsat is a I guess a
platform that's been collecting imagery
of the earth since the mid 70s the
repeat time is every two weeks so every
two weeks the satellite it's going to
take an image of the same place on earth
the pixel size is about 30 meters so
it's not very detailed but it's it's
good enough to
measure the changes that I'm seeing and
it looks like this so it comes it takes
measurements across the visible spectrum
and then into the infrared I use just
the visible images so each band is
basically a black and white image of
reflectance as well you turn them into
reflectance values and then you you put
them together and you get you get images
like the ones I showed in the in the
movie so this is multi spectral data you
can you can infer a lot about the
materials that you're looking at by
investigating all of the bands that the
satellite collects so one of the things
that I do is I take these images and I
try to find out where's the water
if anybody is familiar with remote
sensing this water classification index
is really similar to the vegetation
index that people use to try to classify
plants so what you do is you take in
this case the blue data on the red data
you do a really simple calculation and
you get a map that that looks like this
middle image and other people have done
this and partitioned the the value or
the range of ndwi values that you can
get into shallow medium and deep water
categories and since I'm after water
volume in this budget this at least
gives you a range of possibilities with
a really really simple calculation the
other thing you can do is knowing what
we know about how light interacts with
water you can come up with a physically
based model that instead of using two
bands you just use one band and you say
well I know about how bright the ice is
I know how bright the water is I know I
can guess what a an infinitely deep Lake
might look like and you can get a map
that looks like this one labeled depth
from color and you can see there there
are differences between these two but
they are both picking out the patterns
that your eye would pick out in the
visible image I'm going to talk about
some of the challenges associated with
these mostly in terms of
ndwi what I do is I use this
classification that's kind of a
heuristic for running this depth from
color but you can do one or the other or
both okay so the challenge is associated
with this the ndwi classification
misidentifies shadows as deepwater and
just to orient you again this is the
peeterman ice shelf in Greenland the
ocean is over here ice is flowing from
the bottom of this image to the top this
rock over here is a Ford wall and it's
casting a shadow onto the ice these are
these are crevasses so there's water in
here too and it I was actually really
surprised by this because I can tell
what a shadow is and you can tell what a
shadow is but if you actually look at
the at the spectrum like at the at the
pixel values that are recorded here and
you do the ndwi classification there
spectrally it spectrally basically
indistinguishable from each other so
this is something that will completely
overestimate the water storage and we we
need to take it into account one way you
can do it is by just saying okay I'm
going to make a very conservative mask
of how the shadow is of where the shadow
is cast but then you lose the ability to
analyze the nearby area I've tried to
cast the shadow by knowing something
about the elevation but actually I think
the best way to do this would be to use
some kind of machine learning and like
image segmentation I'm sure someone in
this room could do it that would be that
would be the much better way to go so
the ndwi also messes up with miss
identifying different ice surfaces as
shallow water so it's also going to
overestimate the total total volume
stored these two images are of the same
area the first one shows a really bright
ice surface and it's very clear that
this one is
liquid water there are some areas where
if you have a lot of wind the ice
surface that it is exposed is a little
bit blue and hopefully you can hopefully
you can tell that the one on the one is
this though the right side is is overall
a little bit bluer than the one on the
left if you ran the ndwi on this you
would end up with shallow water
everywhere and we we don't really think
that that's that that's the case this is
a really difficult this is a really
difficult problem to solve because
optically it's you you can't really tell
a lake that has a that that's totally
liquid from one that just has imagine
like a really thin layer of ice on top
of it you would see right through that
you wouldn't know that it was frozen and
this is where satellite radar could come
in and actually tell you about the
material properties of the ice but that
involves incorporating a data set at a
different spatial resolution a different
temporal resolution and a fundamentally
different measurements so I think this
is another interesting data science
problem someone in this room the other
thing is that the atmosphere influences
the the water storage volume estimate
and just to illustrate that point we do
a lot of different Corrections in order
to turn the raw data into reflectance
value that has physical meaning and
usually that involves a correction for
what's happening at the top of the
atmosphere and when you do that you get
the image on the your left and I did a
simple calculation for what the effect
of the atmosphere might be and then you
get the image on the right and hopefully
you can see that that one is a little
bit redder
if you remember the ndwi incorporates
the red and the blue and if you are
looking at the depth from color equation
I used the red band for that so having
the overall image a little bit shifted
towards the red is is a problem
and in order to solve this you can use a
little some ground truth data but again
you want to be able to do this because
properties that the atmosphere change
every day you'd like to be able to do
this just based on the image so that
you're not making assumptions about what
the atmosphere was like last week and
bringing that into the image that you're
collecting this week the last one is
just trying to figure out what is a lake
and what is a river and this isn't - it
doesn't have to be too difficult it's
the difference between a circle and a
line but the thing is that sometimes the
lakes are elongated and sometimes the
rivers are look a little bit broken up
so a river could actually look like a
bunch of small lakes and a lake could
potentially get miss misidentified as a
river depending on its shape I think
this is another possible machine
learning problem or deep learning
problem I don't know I have a vocabulary
problem
so to bring it back to the to the
original question I'm trying to figure
out how much water is stored on an ice
shelf by looking at at Landsat data and
hopefully I've convinced you that it's
possible but there are some challenges
to overcome
I want to overcome these challenges by
analyzing more satellite data including
ground truth data and then possibly
drawing on the expertise of people in
this room so I'm gonna end with what I
think is another much higher resolution
much more beautiful image of the
peeterman ice shelf thank you to all of
my collaborators and advisors and thank
you for your attention
you
you